>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Francisco Macias:
Thank you and welcome.
A special note of thanks before
we begin our program today,
to [inaudible] Rodriguez for
doing all the preparation
and getting us this
wonderful speaker today.
I am Francisco Macias.
I am from the Law Library.
And on behalf of the Library
of Congress Hispanic Division
and the Hispanic Cultural Society,
I would like to welcome you
to today's presentation titled, The
Unlinking of Language and Identity--
Puerto Rican identity-- pardon me.
Which is also the name of the
book authored by our guest,
Dr. Brenda Dominguez-Rosado,
from the University
of Puerto Rico at Bayamon.
Her book melds portions
of her autobiography
and her doctoral studies into
a wonderful introspection
and examination of sociocultural
linguistics and transculturation,
specifically the role of
language and identity.
Dr. Dominguez-Rosado
was born in Fairbanks,
Alaska to a Puerto Rican mother
and a Mexican-American
father from Texas.
Go Texas [laughter].
For 32 years, she has
been an educator
and has been recognized
for her teaching.
At present, she is very
active in academic life
at the University of Puerto Rico.
She has participated
amply at various regional
and international conferences.
Among the countries where she has
presented are Aruba, Cuba, Dominica,
St. Kitts, Barbados, Costa
Rica, Portugal, and Spain.
She is also a consultant
on linguistics
for the Emmy nominated
travel show Isla y Vuelta.
She holds a bachelor of arts
in English with a concentration
in teaching English to Spanish
speakers, a master of arts
in American and British
literature, and a Ph.d. in language
and literature of the
Anglophone Caribbean.
All from the University of
Puerto Rico at Rio Piedras.
Not only is she a scholar, she
has married and accompanied today
by her husband [laughter] and is
the proud mother and grandmother
to two sons and two grandsons.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Brenda Dominguez-Rosado.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
>> Brenda Dominguez-Rosado:
Thank you so much.
>> Francisco Macias: I switched
on languages [laughter].
Very appropriate.
>> Brenda Dominguez-Rosado:
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Well, welcome.
It's a pleasure for me
to be here and thank you
for coming to my presentation.
Although my book is focused--
focuses on the Puerto
Rican experience,
I invite you to insert your
own experiences in life
with language and identity.
It doesn't really matter what
heritage language you might have had
experience with in
your family history.
And ask yourself, is this happening
in my own community as well?
And please share your comments and
your observations or your thoughts
at the end of the presentation.
It will be a whirlwind
30 minute presentation.
I'm going to go fairly quickly, so
some of the slides are text heavy.
Okay? So, hopefully
I won't go too fast.
It's a lot to cover.
The book is based on my
doctoral dissertation
and it is a streamline
version of it.
So, I have made it
more user-friendly
and it has the essence
of my research.
Okay? So, anyway, let
me turn on the control.
All right.
So, I'd like to start with a
really quick introduction to some
of the concepts and terms that I
use in my research, in my book.
First of all, we must acknowledge
that there is a historical link
between language and identity.
Okay? I think we can
all agree on that.
Many, many studies done on that.
But I would like to clarify that
the book addresses more the identity
that is our ethnic
or national identity.
And just to clarify, what I mean
by identity is it's the sense
of belonging to some group.
What we feel we are
or where we belong.
Okay? We must also agree, or
we may agree, or we may know,
that language may be a
core value in cultures.
Okay? Culture is transmitted
through language.
So, it is essential, okay, and
is linked to culture as well.
Attitudes about languages.
The book has to do a
lot with attitudes.
So, it, we, you know, attitudes
about languages are assessments made
about the value of a
particular language.
They can be either positive
or negative attitudes,
and that is very important,
because that influences
the outcome of a language.
A language can be born, a language
can also die because of attitudes.
So, if we have positive attitudes,
that means that we respect,
we admire, we preserve
the language, we use it.
If we don't, then that
means that we don't use it.
That we don't preserve it.
That we don't respect
it and it might die out.
We must also assume that
attitudes are not static.
Okay? They are changing constantly
because of our surrounding
circumstances.
So, we must assume that
they can or should change,
and language policy must
take that into account.
Prevalent language attitudes
provide social indicators
of changing beliefs.
Okay? They're like the thermometer.
They're taking the temperature.
What's going on?
Okay? Are we-- ?
Is it because we're in war?
Is it because we're in peace?
Times of peace, times of war.
I mean, what's going on?
Why is it changing?
Nowadays, the need to confront
and eradicate negative attitudes
and stereotypes may
actually be leading us away
from that traditional stance
of one language, one identity.
Okay? So, times are a changing,
although, if we go back in history,
that's what everybody
said at the time
that they were learning, as well.
A lot of transformation going on.
All right.
So, continuing, some
of you may be familiar
with Puerto Rico, some
of you may not.
So, I'm going to try to
summarize in a nut shell a little
about the history of Puerto Rico
and why we have these two languages
on our island, because we
have Puerto Rican Spanish
and we have American English.
All right?
Now, we also have what we
call the Hispanicisation
and Americanization processes
and they have affected attitude
towards both attitudes towards
those languages.
So, Hispanicisation process
began when the Spaniards arrived
on the island in the
fifteenth century.
They colonized the
island, they were--
they brought their own varieties
of Spanish from the Canary Islands,
from the Andalusian area of
Spain, which is to the south.
They had different varieties.
They had to reach a
common ground in language.
They were greeted by the indigenous
population that already existed
on the island, the Taino.
And, basically, decimated the
Taino population [laughter].
But, you know, some did run for the
hills, okay, and they did survive.
Some of them did.
We still have DNA of the
Taino in Puerto Ricans.
So, they didn't really influence
the language all that much.
But, we do have place
names that exist today
that come from their language.
We also have the Africans,
the slaves that were brought
to our island in the
sixteenth century,
and they also had their
own languages.
They came mostly from the
West coast, the Gold Coast.
They Uribi, the Igbo, people
were the ones who were more--
the ones that arrived the most.
And so, their languages
also had influence
on this emerging new
variety of Spanish
which is known as Puerto
Rican Spanish.
And also, the new and
emerging people known
as the Puerto Rican people.
Okay? So, we're a lovely mixture of
many beautiful people and languages.
And that's Puerto Rican Spanish,
400 years of Puerto Rican
Spanish evolving on the island,
creating a link to identity
for the Puerto Ricans.
And then-- that was 400 years--
and then, we had the
Spanish-American War, where,
as part of the aftermath of
that, Spain handed Puerto Rico
over to the U.S. and
that was in 1898.
And so, it's been about
118, 119 years since then.
The U.S., once they
arrived, immediately said,
Spain is out, U.S. is in [laughter].
Okay? So, now, you're
going to speak English.
And everything is going
to be the way we do it.
Okay? So, that's how it was.
So, the attitudes then, where we
have the positive attitude towards
Spanish, because this is what
we have known for 400 years,
then became a negative
attitude towards English
because it's being imposed.
It wasn't a choice.
It was today you speak--
yesterday you spoke Spanish,
today you're going to speak English.
And schools are in English,
government is in English,
holidays are ours,
everything is ours.
And what you did before
doesn't count anymore.
So, this is where we stand nowadays.
Attitudes are changing.
I just wanted you to know this
because this is why I felt, okay,
there is a change going
on after 100 years.
All right?
So, this is where we stand.
Now, at the bottom, I
have a little comment.
I've noticed, and many
people have noticed,
that there is a global
tendency towards multilingualism
and pluriculturalism, so I
mean, is it that we're special?
I mean, is this change going on in
Puerto Rico only, or is it going
on in the world and we're just
following a global tendency?
All right?
So, that's one of the
important questions.
Okay. So, the selection of my
topic for the dissertation/book,
because the book is based
on the dissertation,
I've had my own struggles with
identity related to language.
And very briefly, my dad was
Mexican-American from Texas,
as was explained already.
My mother from Puerto Rico.
My household, we were not
raised speaking Spanish,
even though my parents
were Hispanic.
They only spoke Spanish
to each other
when they didn't want the children
to know what they were
talking about [laughter].
Okay. So, my first
language is English,
but I look Hispanic, I think.
Right? And my father
was in the Army.
We were at a base, we were
living on a base in Texas.
Although, at that point, when
this experience happened,
we were off base.
So, I was at a school where it
was a public school, but off base,
so everybody from other--
the community.
Not people necessarily related to
the Army were attending the school.
One student-- I was
in the seventh grade--
one student approached me and she
asked me something in Spanish.
And, I just blankly stared at her.
I had no idea what she was asking.
So, she thought I hadn't heard her,
so she repeats the
question in Spanish.
And, I was just, again,
and she says--
and then she said to me in
English, don't you understand?
And I said, no.
And she says, what kind
of a Mexican are you?
[laughter] And I said, oh my-- .
I was just shocked.
I didn't know-- .
I didn't say anything.
I was thinking, I had never thought
of myself, you know, as Mexican,
as Puerto Rican, as
I was just American.
I was just an Army brat.
I was just in middle school.
I really had no idea, but it
was like a slap in the face.
And I'm thinking, my goodness,
what kind of Mexican am I?
I don't know.
I guess I'm not a Mexican.
But then we moved to
Puerto Rico when I was
in the ninth grade and
my parents divorced.
My mother returned to Puerto Rico.
And I was immersed into
a Spanish speaking world.
Because even though our language is
the official languages are English
and Spanish, English is not used
that much in the official sphere.
I mean, it's just the
federal court, for example.
We do have English
taught from kindergarten
to the University levels, but
people, the majority who study,
basically, and study, who study in
public school do not become fluent
in English, unfortunately.
So, it's a struggle.
So, anyway, I was immersed
into the Spanish speaking world
and then it became a question of
what kind of Puerto Rican are you?
You don't speak Spanish [laughter].
Okay. And I was immediately
labeled Nuyorican [laughter].
They'd say, oh, that Nuyorican.
Okay. I had never been in New York
[laughter], hadn't been born there.
No. So, anyways, what do you mean?
So, I was labeled.
I was discriminated against.
I was also called gringa.
Okay. That American girl, you know.
So, I felt like an outsider.
It was a huge incentive
to learn Spanish.
Let me just tell you
that [laughter].
I learned it very quickly.
But, I felt like an outsider.
So this is part of it.
And since I lived this experience
myself, I know what it feels like.
And I could, because I've been
an educator for the past 32 years
and I started teaching--
I'm an English professor--
I started noticing these attitudes
changing in my own classes
when I started teaching
high school in 1984,
the students were not
that eager to learn.
You know? It was like
the rebellious thing.
It was the oppressor's language.
You know? So, but things
have changed.
And I said, you know what?
This is a wonderful topic.
I feel so personally, that
it's a personal thing for me.
So, I think that when
you're passionate
about something, it
works out better.
Okay. So, I did a pilot study and
that showed interesting trends.
The pilot study is
documented in the book.
Okay? Research question.
So, is Puerto Rican Spanish still
seen as a fundamental requirement
for Puerto Rican identity?
Number two, if people cannot
speak Puerto Rican Spanish, PRS,
were not born or do
not live on the island,
can they call themselves
Puerto Rican?
Okay. What-- is there a changing
attitude towards American English
and Puerto Rican society?
Number four, what are the
attitudes towards the importance
of Puerto Rican Spanish and
American English as linked
to identity among our younger
university educated generation
versus the attitudes of
the older generations
who are university educated or not,
who are not educated at
the university level?
Or even less than that?
What are the causes of any change
in attitude that may be detected?
Can people identify
themselves as Puerto Rican
if they have native
fluency in English?
How much has U.S. culture
influenced Puerto Rican culture?
Is there a harmonious integration?
And number nine - - there were
more questions, by the way, okay--
can Puerto Ricans take their
place on the international stage
by becoming proudly multilingual
yet maintaining their
identity as Puerto Ricans?
So, all of those questions
were answered, and more.
Now, I just wanted to, very quickly,
go over my theoretical framework.
This is dissertationese,
okay, from the dissertation,
but I just wanted you to know
that I did look at things
from a historical perspective.
I wanted to see if I could detect
change from different generations.
So, I wanted to start with
grandparents, then parents,
then the university students,
to see if over this 100 year
period there was a change
and if I could actually
document it that way.
And that's why I have focus groups.
Functional theory, I noticed that
well, it affects peoples' wallets.
So, if you make money by knowing
English, if job opportunities open
up for you because you're bilingual,
then this is something positive
that is affecting the change.
Then I also have the
cognitive dissonance theory
where when you have
opposing-- sorry--
opposing attitudes
that are not congruent,
you want bilingual
education for your children,
but you don't like
the English language,
okay, something has to change.
Okay? So, if you--
then you have sort
of a new positive attitude
towards the English.
And language and identity ties
that do not necessarily bind.
There is a tendency now
of unlinking language.
It's not as like, oh, that's
the main requirement globally.
Okay. I use a questionnaire.
And the questionnaire had a double
purpose; it was for results.
I asked the questions,
people answered.
But, also, I wanted to
recruit the families
so I had very strict requirements
that they had to fulfill.
They had to be of Puerto
Rican ancestry.
They had to reside on the island.
They had to be literate.
And they also had to
be willing to cooperate
with no incentive whatsoever
[laughter].
Okay? Just a snack and some
water or something, you know.
So, and be able to meet on
the same day, same time.
So, it was a difficult process.
I also had, as I said, the focus
groups that were recruited.
This is the methodology
very quickly.
I had to get authorization,
obviously.
The questionnaire.
I had to-- .
This-- I had problems encountered.
You'll see that at the
bottom, the little list.
I had to go out into the hallways
and find people to participate
that were 21 years and older.
And I work at an undergrad
institution,
so the majority are
not older than 21.
It was difficult.
We were at the end of the semester,
because by the time I
had received permission,
it was already final exam time.
So, I was like, oh no!
I was wondering the hallways
[laughter], stopping people
and then, show me your
I.D. [laughter].
No, I'm not the police [laughter].
So, the thing is that I was
finally able to get enough people
to answer the questionnaire to
be able to recruit my families
because they had to be willing to
collaborate and cooperate with me.
Okay? So, the initial
plan was to have 20.
Then I was only able to get-- .
I said, no, 20 is too
many, too many, too much.
10, and then that dream was slashed,
and then I finally
was able to get 5.
And then, finally, at the very
end, 2 families had difficulty,
so I ended up with 3 families.
So, anyway.
But, I was able to then
have the focus groups.
And then the students were
one female, two males.
Parents were three males.
Grandparents were two
females and one male.
I interviewed them.
I gave them a choice
of Spanish or English.
They all chose Spanish.
So, once I finished the interviews,
I transcribed, by myself,
no machine, no helper, no assistant.
These were hours of tapes.
And then I had to translate
from Spanish to English.
And then analyze and
choose, you know,
what I thought were more appropriate
quotes than-- for the book.
Okay? So, it was a lot
of work, in other words.
Anyway, my salient findings.
That speaking Puerto Rican Spanish
is not an essential requirement
for Puerto Rican identity.
And I have some quotes
that I have included.
I'm going-- I'm not going
to read all of them.
But, just so you know,
these were some
of the things that they expressed.
And all were in agreement.
So, this is from the questionnaires
and from the focus groups.
The link is not necessarily
present because an individuals
or Puerto Rican society's identity
is defined by more than a language.
Language is clearly important,
but there are other things,
like culture, religion, customs,
that also help form a
personal and social identity.
So, I don't consider
it to be essential.
There's more demographic information
about all my participants
in the book.
Okay? But, I was allowed to
identify them by their initials.
Number two, to be able to claim
Puerto Rican identity does not
require you to be born on the
island or even reside on the island.
And E.R., the grandparent, said,
even if you are born American-- .
Okay, I don't have time to
explain [laughter], yeah.
But yes, there is that,
if you're not-- .
If you're from over here,
then you're American, okay,
and live in the U.S. If you're
parents are Puerto Rican,
they're always going to
instill in you feelings
about being Puerto Rican.
In other words, you have to feel
it like the singer Marc Anthony,
who was born and raised over there,
the U.S., but who always talks
about his Puerto Rican roots.
I don't believe that
that impedes anything.
I'd like to read the other quote,
because it also shows how the
younger generation is thinking.
I have family members
in New York and some
of my cousins have never
even visited Puerto Rico,
but they are proud to call
themselves Puerto Rican.
And they don't have a
complete mastery of Spanish,
but they follow many of our Puerto
Rican customs and defend them
and are even prouder
of them than we are.
Okay. And, American English is
being seen in a more positive light.
This is a grandparent.
He says, well, in the
past, the attitude was one
of complete rejection, because
we lacked human resources
who could teach us and we preferred
to speak our vernacular instead
of the imported language.
It is still being rejected by my
generation, but to a lesser extent,
because we need to use
it in our daily lives
because it's practically
a universal language,
and it's necessary for everything.
And then the younger generation.
They, the older generations,
might have associated learning
English while leaving their Puerto
Rican-- with leaving their
Puerto Rican identity behind,
but our generation is more open
and we can understand that just
because we learn another
language, we're not going
to stop being Puerto Rican.
And we can still feel
proud of who we are.
So, having a university
education is not a major factor
in the new attitude towards
English on the island.
They all agreed and they were
of varying levels of education.
Number five, the use of technology
has been instrumental in the change
of attitude-- in attitude
towards American English,
and that includes social
media and film and tv.
Okay? So, we are bombarded by
all of the media that comes
from the U.S. and English.
Native fluency in English or
being multilingual does not appear
to affect Puerto Rican identity.
So, the parent said, even
if you speak perfect English
and you're Puerto Rican,
it doesn't mean
that you stop being Puerto Rican.
That has nothing to do with it.
I think we can integrate more
languages and still be Puerto Rican.
Number seven, a new
culture with American
and Puerto Rican components may
be in the process of formation.
This is an interesting phenomenon
and I'd love to do a, you know,
further study on that topic.
And I'm sure that here
in the diaspora as well,
a new culture is forming.
You have-- you use what you
have available and you make,
you know, you make it your own.
Right? Something new.
So, at the bottom, we have
the grandparents saying, yes,
we have been influenced, sometimes
dramatically, such as in food.
Before, we didn't know
what fast food was.
People ate rice and beans at
their local rustic restaurants.
In la fonda, as we
say in Puerto Rico.
But now, it's hot dog,
hamburger, sushi, sirloin,
and who knows what the
devil else [laughter].
Okay? He was really fun to
interview, let me tell you.
He was great.
Puerto Rico-- oops, sorry--
Puerto Ricans enjoy brotherly
or neighborly relationships
with other Caribbean nations,
but they are perceived
differently by them
because of their relationship to
the U.S. Becoming multilingual
in pluricultural will not
change this perception.
So, I'm going to read the
one from the grandparent.
We're all neighbors and if
some people speak one language
and others speak another,
it doesn't mean anything.
We're still neighbors.
Okay? They do see us as
different, very different, however,
because we depend on another
nation, the United States.
They, other Latin Americans
from neighboring islands,
call us the kept people
of the Caribbean,
lo monte nebo la Caribe [laughter].
It's a pseudonym that
we've been assigned
and it's definitely affecting
attitudes towards us.
It's a give and take with the
U.S., but we're still dependent.
This is something very deep.
It's something you can barely touch
upon because it bothers us so much.
Okay? And so, on that
note, the implications.
The findings mentioned here
are the result of a study
with a limited number
of participants.
I do not wish to imply
that the opinions
of the participants represent
the majority of Puerto Ricans.
To do so would be an absurd claim.
However, the present study and
its findings do open the door
into future research
into the topics analyzed.
The results appear to
indicate that language
and identity issues are
changing on the island.
The findings also indicate
that at least some Puerto
Ricans are aligning themselves,
both with their Caribbean
and global neighbors,
in terms of attitudes
towards language and identity.
An apparent change in progress has
been documented in the responses
of the participants from three
Puerto Rican generations reflecting
a shift from a monolingual,
monocultural identity
to a bilingual, bicultural
one and a willingness
to accept multilingualism and
pluriculturalism as tools needed
to survive in a world
that is becoming smaller
and more accessible
because of technology.
Update. Okay.
So, my new 2016 study is not related
directly to language and identity,
but it was about Puerto
Rican Spanish and prestige.
Okay? I presented this, the
results, last year in Spain.
But, I snuck in a question
about language and identity.
So, on this online survey,
I had 979 participants,
but I only considered the ones
that were complete
responses; that was 902.
Some people were non-Puerto Ricans.
Okay? So, those were 50; 50 people.
So, the majority were Puerto Ricans.
These are the results.
If you take a look at the red
bars, those are the Puerto Ricans.
The tan or the beige bars are--
well, I don't know
if you can see them--
but they are the non-Puerto Ricans.
And you'll see that for
agree and completely agree,
we have 291 agree,
273 completely agree.
And if we add those up it's
564 out of 881 Puerto Ricans
who corroborate my previous
findings in 2010 and 2012.
There is a new tendency
towards unlinking
because of a large diaspora
that doesn't speak Spanish
yet claims a Puerto Rican identity.
The non-Puerto Ricans also
mainly supported the idea.
Okay. Recommendations.
A broader study needs to be
completed where the apparent change
in progress concerning attitudes
towards the link between languages
and identity in Puerto Rico
can be more fully documented.
And I am on it, okay [laughter],
because I have already
created a new survey.
It's online.
It's waiting for permission
at my campus
and at the other ten UPR campuses.
So, I am expanding out to
the other ten campuses to see
if they also reflect the same
findings to have a larger sample.
And, I'm waiting for permission,
so I'm still in the process,
but it's going to be done.
Number two, more studies
should be conducted
in the Puerto Rican diaspora.
Okay. And concerning
language and identity, do--
my question is, do they see the link
the same way as islanders do or not?
Okay? What is their
essential requirement
for establishing a
Puerto Rican identity?
My next major project will be
to visit the diasporan cities
in the U.S. and in Saint Croix
where there is a large Puerto Rican
diaspora, U.S. Virgin Islands,
in order to replicate
the original study
with the questionnaire
and the focus groups.
Although, I'm thinking it will
probably be the questionnaire.
The focus groups is--
was very up hill.
Okay. And, conclusion.
The quest for determining the
link between language and identity
on the island of Puerto Rico has
lead to thought provoking results.
The traditional viewpoint of
promoting Puerto Rican Spanish
as the bearer of Puerto Rican
identity and American English
as the bearer of unwelcome
intrusion now appears to be evolving
into a modern attitude
of acceptance of the idea
that languages can function
independently of identity.
Also, the two cultures present on
the island seem to be entwining
and creating a syncretic new
variety unique to Puerto Rico.
To all appearances, it seems that
a new identity is being forged.
One that is not linked to
any particular language,
but rather includes
the heart of a people
and their evolving traditions,
customs, and beliefs.
And you may access the dissertation.
It's a really long
title, it's not the same.
If you put my name on, Brenda
Dominguez-Rosado, it will--
the title will come up on
ProQuest at your favorite library;
probably the Library
of Congress [laughter].
Okay? All right.
Or, you can purchase my book online.
It's on Amazon.
I was looking for it and,
you know, this weekend.
It's disappeared from other stores.
I don't know.